That's not funny.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie. Big surprise,
Marvel
and Sony dropped a brand new Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse trailer
with a whole bunch of new Easter eggs.
A whole bunch of new versions
of Spider-Man
in the most epic pointing meme
that you have ever seen.
Like literally every single version
of Spider-Man that ever
was on the spider boards here,
pointing at each other at the same time.
They even literally reference
the events of Spider-Man
No Way Home with MCU, Spider-Man in Doctor
Strange.
Don't Even Get Me Started on Doctor
Strange and The Little Nerd
Back on Earth, 19 9999.
Everyone thought I was Spider-Man before.
Just Still don't.
Did it work?
There's even a horse
version of Spider-Man.
I'll explain who that is because he is
out of the Spider-Verse comics.
If you're brand do to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
They'll be a bunch more trailers for this
and other things coming up really soon.
It's kind of like trailer fest
the last couple of days.
They start the trailer with Miles Morales
narrating the last couple of years.
He's already wearing his newer version
of his ultimate Spider-Man costume.
You know,
the logo's a little more polished.
That's how,
you know, he's wearing the new suit.
He explains what's been happening
the last couple of years,
Like he's still trying
to make his way through school.
They have a couple of funny moments
with that, but he's been busy
just trying to save people
around his neighborhood.
He's experiencing
a lot of the classic Spider-Man tropes
where he's never on time for anything.
Everybody thinking about Tobey Maguire,
Spider-Man two, It's pizza time.
Joe's 29 minute guarantee is a promise.
Peter Parker never being dependable.
Now Miles
Morales is having the same problem.
Like, you're never on time.
You're never around when we need you
because he's busy out
trying to be Spider-Man.
He winds up meeting the main
villain of the movie The Spot.
For the first time.
He's voiced by Jason Schwartzman.
The spot is from the comics.
You basically see his powers here
where he can open up portals.
He winds up being very hard to fight
because he can open up portals
all over his body of different sizes, too.
They featured him during Spider-Man,
the animated series during the 1990s.
He jokingly asked him
if he's a cow because he's
white with the black spots like a cow.
Even though during the trailer they played
like Spider-Man 2099 is an antagonist
to Miles Morales because all the rest
of the other versions of Spider-Man
from the multiverse come after him
like he calls out a hit on Spider-Man.
Everybody stop what you're doing
and take down Ultimate Spider-Man.
Miles Morales.
I think part of what the spot is doing
has something to do with the way
the multiverse is broken in Spider-Man
2099 is trying to fix it
because he directly references
the events of Doctor Strange,
Multiverse of Madness in Spider-Man.
No way home with that kid
like the nerd from Earth, 19 9999.
It literally references Doctor Strange.
That's
meant to be a reference to Spider-Man
No Way Home with the two spells and Doctor
Strange Messing with the Multiverse
in Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness.
But he also blames Miles Morales
for the events
in the first movie with Kingpin's reactor
messing with the multiverse.
So part of the reason why Spider-Man 2099
has created the Spider Forces multiverse
versions of Spider-Man
and give them all this web
where wristwatches is to fix
all the problems in the multiverse caused
by these other big movies
like The First Spider-Man
into the Spider-Verse movie,
The problems
that they caused during Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness with the incursions
in the problems
that they caused in Spider-Man
No Way Home, where Tom Holland, MCU,
Spider-Man messed up the spell and started
pulling all the different versions
of villains to his Earth, as well
as other versions of Spider-Man two.
There was a rumor
that they would reference Tobey
Maguire and Andrew Garfield Spider-Man
during this too.
I didn't see them specifically
in the trailer,
but because they're referencing the events
in Spider-Man, No Way Home you can look at
that is a reference to those characters.
The whole joke with his counselor here
is that he's getting a B in Spanish
and his mom gets really pissed off
because she is Hispanic,
like he's half Hispanic,
so she wants him to speak it fluently.
In the other joke here
is that he's having this meeting
while he's in the middle of meeting
the spot for the first time, like, Oh,
just hit pause on this meeting.
I got to go
take care of something real quick.
That I'll be right back.
Very Spider-Man type of problem to have
when the guidance counselor also tells
his parents that he's lying to you
and you probably know what's going on.
That's them teasing that his parents
will find out that he is Spider-Man
during the events of the movie.
Either he'll tell them his secret
or they'll find out on their own.
There's the same scene of Spider
Gwen coming to get him earlier
in the movie, showing him the spider
for space Multiverse base of Spider-Man.
They do a quick montage of the spider
force, the major characters.
This is meant to be Jessica Drewe, Spider
Woman, played by Issa Rae.
You notice that she is very,
very pregnant.
Like spider woman in the comics.
We get a bunch
more footage of Holby Brown, Spider punk.
This is what he looks like
without the costume on, too.
The other big thing about his character
is that in the movie, he's
meant to be a big mentor to Spider
Gwen and gives her the Chuck Taylors
that she wears in the movie.
So her main spider Gwen costume
is the same from the first movie,
but she's changed
her ballet shoes for the Chuck Taylors
given to her by Spider Punk.
The other things you notice in this scene
is the way they animate his music,
playing like it's a very punk rock
looking animation style.
They say that they did that
for all the different characters,
like when you go to Spider-Man,
Indias world in the city of Mountbatten,
which is kind of like their version
of New York in that world.
The way they animate everything
on that earth completely changes.
But the characters themselves
each keep their unique animation style.
They had an army of people animating this.
You have to imagine,
okay, we're going to animate
different parts of this movie
in completely different ways.
Probably one of the other
biggest surprises to just talking about
the animation style is when you see
Ben Riley at the end of the trailer
and he looks literally like he jumped off
of a comic book page,
Like they're all animated characters
because it's an animated movie.
But the way the animators character
makes it look like someone just ripped him
right off of the comic book page.
We get to see Spider-Man, India,
swinging around on his world.
If the voice sounds familiar,
that's because it's Kieren Sony,
who plays Joe Pinder in the Deadpool
movies.
He's coming back in Deadpool three, too.
So now he's also coming into the MCU
in live action.
We get the same scene of Miles Morales
seeing the spider for space
for the first time
from that first trailer with the billion
different versions of Spider-Man
and the joke that is just the lobby like
you think this is fantastic.
It gets way crazier than this.
I already did a much longer video
pointing out every single different
version of Spider-Man
who they are, so I'll link
that video down below in the description.
But just to mention a couple
of my favorite ones here on the left
is Spider Cop.
Behind him, scenes
like the Manga versus Spider-Man.
Zoom out again.
You see the bombastic man next to him,
I believe is a variant of Flash
Thompson Spider-Man from the comics
wearing the Midtown High Letterman jacket.
This is Anya Corazon.
This is Superior Spider-Man.
This is six armed Spider-Man
who grabs him with all of his arms,
along with a version
of the classic spider armor.
This is one of the newer spider
armor suits.
It could also be
the Fortnite version of Spider-Man two.
Then this isn't meant to be MCU,
Spider-Man, Tom Holland.
This is still a piece for Spider-Man.
The same red variant next to him in
what looks like a suit from the later
Secret Wars event.
This is Kain over on the left.
For those of you
hoping that Cain would be in here.
There's also spider monkey up top.
Spider Gwen starts explaining
how everything works. Who?
Spider-Man 2099 is Miguel Ohara.
You see him
fighting a version of The Vulture,
which looks much more like
comic book vulture.
She basically explains what happened
at the end of the first movie
in the Post-Credits scene where he created
the Web, where wristwatches inserted
to create the spider force and try to fix
all the different tiers in the multiverse
like everybody causing incursions
all over the place,
which is what they're doing in Marvel
Phase four, Phase five, and Phase
six with this whole Kang the Conqueror
storyline and the Council of Kings.
So it's kind of like they're tying
the events of this movie
and all these problems in the multiverse
to what's happening in Avengers five, Qing
Dynasty, in Avengers six Secret Wars,
which also makes me think
that at the end of these two movies,
because they just did
the Avengers, Infinity
War and Avengers Endgame thing
with Spider-Man across the Spider-Verse.
So instead of one movie,
they actually split into two.
The third movie now,
which is basically like part two of Across
the Spider-Verse, is called Spider-Man
Beyond the Spider-Verse.
I think that during Spider-Man, beyond
the Spider-Verse, he is going to come into
live action like, we'll see this
Miles Morales in live action.
It'll just be the same version.
That's probably why
they've been waiting to cast a live action
version of the character,
because it's going to be the version
that we've seen in the Spider-Verse movie
so far.
We get another shot of the characters
walking from a different angle
in the spider force.
This one up from the right seems like
a classic version of the 616 Spider-Man.
The one behind him in the armor seems like
a version of Fortnite's Spider-Man.
When Miguel O'Hara's Spider-Man 2099 says,
You can never join the spider force.
Like I said,
that has something to do with him
blaming the events of the first movie
on Miles Morales.
But he also blames Doctor Strange
in that nerd from Earth 199999.
That's basically MCU.
Tom Holland's Spider-Man.
That's
where we get to the connections to the MCU
and what's happening with Avengers five,
Qing Dynasty, Avengers six, Secret Wars.
Like everything
Louie's seen in the live action
movies is stuff
that they're referencing in this movie.
All the multiverse consequences,
the problems
the characters have been causing
for the last several movies.
Spider-Man 2099 has been trying to use
this team of Spider-Man to fix all those.
Peter B Parker comes to defend him.
Don't blame the kid.
He had a terrible teacher
like he's making fun of himself.
And we see Mayday Parker,
who's got her own babies sized webs, like
she's got her own mechanical web shooter
that Peter B Parker has made for her.
But it's designed
like something that a baby would wear.
There's some serious parenting going on
right there.
Later in the trailer,
you see that she's wearing a baby bonnet,
but it's knitted to look like a Spider-Man
mask, like they needed her a Spider-Man
mask bonnet, foreshadowing her becoming
a version of Spider Woman eventually.
She's meant to be the child
that he wound up having with his version
of Mary Jane after he reunited with her
at the end of the first movie.
This scene of Spider
Gwen is a flashback of her and her version
of Peter Parker on her earth
that wound up dying.
It's part of her story in her relationship
with Miles Morales in this movie.
Part of the reason
why she's hesitant to actually start
going out with him,
like sort of relationship with him
is because during the movie,
she says that every version of Gwen winds
up falling in love
with a version of Peter Parker
and it always winds up ending tragically,
which is a reference to Amazing Spider-Man
two, Gwen Stacy dying.
There's actually a moment like that
with Miles
Morales, his father, in this trailer.
If you're not familiar with Spider Gwen's
backstory, though, in her backstage,
the unique twist is
it is Peter Parker that dies tragically.
So during this scene,
she's just remembering that.
We get the voiceover Spider-Man 2099,
giving the space to Miles Morales.
It's all about the needs
of the many versus the needs of the few.
Do you save the one person
that you really care about, or
do you try to save every single world
instead?
Also, if you didn't remember,
Oscar Isaac is playing Spider-Man 2099.
He played Spider-Man 2099 in the first
movie, too very meta, with him
referencing MCU, Spider-Man
and Tom Holland in Doctor Strange.
Maybe he'll reference Moonlight.
Maybe there'll be some jokes about that.
We'll see.
In Miles Morales is trying to explain
to him like his big argument against
that is that his story doesn't
have to be similar to the other variants
of Peter Parker.
Spider-Man like he's Miles Morales.
His story can be completely different
because he's from a different universe.
Also,
when he's talking about the Spider-Man
2099, you see him in bat
and trying to save Spider Gwen.
So it seems like during the movie
they're teasing that he'll have to choose
whether or not to save his family over
saving the entire multiverse.
This girl here
who's facing all over the spider force
base might actually be a female gender
bending version of Miles Morales
from another Earth.
Part of the whole idea of the movie
is we're seeing multiverse
versions of the character.
It'd be crazy
if we didn't see another version of Miles
Morales from a different Universe.
Miles Morales tries to argue with all
the versions of Spider-Man about Uncle.
Like what about Uncle Ben?
What if you could save Uncle Ben
in Spider-Man 2099 tries to explain to him
that if not for Uncle Ben, most of them
would not have become Spider-Man?
So sometimes people do have to die.
We get a longer version
of that scene of him escaping the spider
force base, jumping into the portal.
This might be a wide shot of a different
part of the spider force base.
Or it might just be where two ers collide
with each other through these portals.
Like you see
all the different versions of Spider-Man
chasing Miles Morales
across a couple different universes.
This part of the Chase scene is basically
all the versions of Spider-Man
chasing him through Nueva York,
Spider-Man 2099 Earth.
We finally get Ben Riley already
explained his unique animation,
and we get that epic pointing meme
where we get Spider-Man PS4 pointing
at Spider-Man Unlimited from that TV show,
also pointing at a version of what
seems like the classic 616 Spider-Man.
It every other version of Spider-Man ever
doing the pointing meme with each other.
Then they have a scene very similar
to the Iron Man three Post-Credits
scene where the Hulk was giving therapy
to Iron Man, where you have the business
suit, Spider-Man giving therapy to this
classic 616 version of Spider-Man.
And it seems like he's explaining his past
trauma with Uncle Ben's death
as the entire spider forms.
All these versions of Spider-Man
crashed through this universe, chasing
Miles Morales in probably one of my new
favorite versions in the trailer
that we haven't seen in previous trailers
is this horse version of Spider-Man.
He is from the Spider-Verse Comics.
His name is Widow.
His rider is a version of Spider-Man
as well, who's a cowboy named Webslinger.
Everyone let me know in the comments
what your favorite Easter egg
from the trailer like,
What's your favorite
new version of Spider-Man
that we saw in this trailer
that wasn't in the previous trailers?
Most people probably going to say Ben
Riley or the horse version of Spider-Man
or The Big Doctor Strange in MCU,
Tom Holland's Spider-Man call Out.
There's so many Easter eggs
and references in the trailer.
You could look at this all day
and still find new stuff.
So if there's any big ones
that you spotted that
I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
Everyone click here for my brand
new Marvel Secret Invasion trailer video
and click here for that brand new Blue
Beetle trailer video and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.